Stars, galaxies, in astral seas above, on cosmic paths we'll trace, man's silver wings.
Liberty is such a wonder thing, behind us all, come see, come take your place, we're leaving soon for...
Be successful. Good as new. That's the main thing. A couple of weeks, they should be gone.
You must have suffered, my lad. No.
It was a little bit your own fault.
That's true. I swear, next time I'll listen to your intuition.
Yes, but the next time we return to that planet, according to the council's recommendation, we'll be in a hundred million years.
Yes, well, that's quite right. A hundred million years. Well, that's how long it is from the time the dinosaurs disappeared and the true Homo erectus appeared.
Well, go on, Metro. Show us what you can do. Go on, Willard.
Eh, how's this for openers?
In case you have to be rescued again, at least you'll be more comfortable.
Yeah, thanks a lot. The celestial scooter, the orbital bike, like a circus act, and with my superior intellect.
with my knowledge of science my lightning calculations ridiculous i don't want to take
too much of your valuable time madam president but the director of the geophysical section said
you were the only one who could help yes that's right i have received your request psyche but
you must realize releasing a spacecraft for a private mission hardly conforms with a strict
interpretation of the rules even the tiniest craft would do i mean i could carry out the mission with
a space book surely it's possible to assign non-essential craft to missions even when they
Well, it's like this. Out in space, there's a mystery that has always fascinated me as a geophysicist.
In the solar system, somewhere between Jupiter and Mars, some 500 million kilometers from Earth, there is a ring of asteroids.
According to some theories, they are residue, stellar debris or space dust that never gravitated to form a planet in the formation and evolution of the solar system itself.
But, according to other theories, a planet did exist there once.
And millions of years ago there was a colossal war between two galactic powers.
One of them believed that their enemy had taken refuge in the fifth planet.
They were to be the winners, possessing an extraordinarily high degree of technology.
They decided to blow up that planet. This resulted in the belt of asteroids.
In fact, their enemies had taken refuge in the third planet of the system, Earth,
where their presence created many legends.
Today we have scientific means for determining the age and nature of each asteroid.
asteroid. And I believe their origin. If my theory is correct, it will confirm the existence somewhere in the cosmos of a civilization perhaps hundreds of millions of years old and with an extraordinary degree of technology. I have a month's vacation now. I'd like to go there and investigate if you'll allow me. You and Pierrot have made an excellent team. Indeed, I would like to take this occasion to congratulate you two on all your successes. Your own knowledge and skill have rendered considerable service. Yes, you may go. In any case, the present situation will be possible.
is calm. Our colleagues in Cassiopeia are quiet, a cause for worry in itself, perhaps.
Your request is granted. You will have your spacecraft, but don't go into space alone.
I know just the one who'd like to go.
Had this mini-craft, right, Nitro? It's called a space bug.
Scientifically speaking, a space insect would be...
Now what?
I bumped my head. But don't mind me. I don't matter. I am modified remodeled for your comfort.
But where is my comfort? They just stuffed me into this galactic gnat, this insect, what do you call it?
Oh, you're always complaining. You're a pain in the neck, you know that?
It's always the same. Robot, switch off.
Look, Metro, maybe you'd rather have stayed on Omega.
Ask me that later. It's always the same, these outings. Nothing ever happens.
All right, have your little joke, Metro.
Well, almost nothing. I'd say, ah, yes, golden bar. Now, that was quite interesting.
Another one like that, and I'd say I was very glad I came.
Uranus, how green it is.
Green because its layer of methane absorbs all other colors.
Nights, 42 years long, and the days too, of course, naturally.
Rather interesting.
Mass, 100 times that of the Earth.
The rings are made of rock, debris, and ice.
That's Oberon, one of the planet's satellites.
And there are two others, Ariel and Umbriel.
I know them all.
There's Saturn.
I'm really looking forward to seeing its rings.
So beautiful.
Saturn, a strange planet.
After Jupiter, the largest in the solar system, 800 times the size of Earth,
composed mainly of hydrogen and helium.
So light, it would float in the ocean.
If you could find an ocean big enough.
Here we go.
The Cassini division is large enough to let us through.
All set?
Am I all set?
Hey, you know me.
Thousand rings formed out of rock and ice.
Width, 60,000 kilometers.
Thickness, only 16 kilometers.
Rather like a cigarette paper.
Thin.
From edge to edge, 275,000 kilometers.
Approximately the space occupied by the Earth.
Anyone for billiards?
Sorry, there.
That's Encelade.
One of its moons, Saturn has 17 moons in all.
Good Arctic landscape.
Titan, the largest of the satellites.
Larger than the planet Mercury.
And is Thetis.
Mimas, closest to the planet.
A mere 180,000 kilometers.
Shall we have a look?
This is a real show.
What do you say we slow down?
You will follow us to our base.
This is only a routine check.
We will show you the way.
Who are you?
What do you want?
Your questions will be answered.
Now obey instructions.
I'm from Omega, intergalactic Greece.
You'll explain all that later.
Obey instructions.
We don't wish to destroy you.
Contact Omega as fast as you can.
Get through.
Radio isn't functioning.
You come here.
Geological research on the asteroids.
Just who are you?
We are ones who ask questions.
No, the asteroids that you speak of are located several million kilometers distance from here.
You are incorrect.
You are on observation flight, not only travel.
Your response is illogical.
You lie.
I've always been fascinated by Saturn's rings.
and it was an ideal occasion to observe them close.
That's the reason that I came.
You say you are intergalactic space patrol,
then geologist, geophysicist.
Now you say on vacation.
Data not compatible.
Respond logically.
It's all quite lovely.
Three statements are true.
I have authorization to be here.
That's why I'd like to know more.
Your analysis of situation is incorrect.
At present, we regret.
We will give you time to revise your responses.
Seeing an adventure and fun.
Hey, sure, sure, that's what they promised.
And then what do I get?
I rushed away in some tin can jail in a forgotten whole of the universe.
Rather interesting, we just might end up having a good time.
Data incompatible.
Respond logically, respond logically.
Your analysis of situation is incorrect. Your analysis of situation is incorrect.
Wrong here. The way he spoke to me, as if I were a machine or something mechanical.
We trust you are in better condition now.
Well, what are you doing here?
I can only give you the same answer.
Are you alone? Are there other spaceships?
Again, I repeat, I'm alone. There's no one else.
What does Omega know about us?
They don't even know you exist.
Then exactly what are you doing here?
You're tall. You're only imitations, humanoids, machines.
The truth is, that's what you are.
How do you know that?
What else do you know?
Yes, yes, it's her, it's her, yes, that's her.
You recognize her?
Yes, I do. She's dangerous, quite dangerous.
I wouldn't take any chances with her.
And if you could make her tall, reveal her secrets,
well then, it would help us in our surveillance of Omega, do you understand?
Have no disquiet. We will do.
Where is your knowledge stored?
What is your knowledge?
You will never understand.
You will never reduce human intelligence to computer level.
Intuition, reasoning, insight, feelings, communication between people.
On all levels, you will never know it.
We will see about that.
You excite yourself.
Not logical.
Not rational.
Wrong.
Where is your knowledge stored?
What is your knowledge?
Respond.
We have ways of making you talk.
They sleep.
Where is your knowledge stored?
Where is your knowledge?
Respond.
You will be free.
We have ways of making you talk.
See if this continues.
Courage, Psyche.
You must not despair.
Evil must not triumph over good.
May the Force be with you.
What's been six days and still no word from Psyche?
Let me go.
You're still not well enough to travel.
But I'll request our base at Vesta to send out a patrol.
Oh, but Dad, you know that Psyche and I have a telepathic kind of communication.
if she's in trouble it's me she'll try to contact dad something's wrong i know how you feel son but
you're not fit to go into hyperspace alone well then give me a co-pilot why not slugger like in
the good old days here i can't stand any more of this great god's house don't be alarmed this
gentleman go keep us any trouble for the moment but i would hurry up if i were you you never know
when the others will come the way i'm sure you were aware that this big fellow is a piece of
machinery a robot of sorts indeed just as i am of course his circuits are barbaric compared to mine
Look at him. He follows my orders.
Careful. TV camera.
Quite interesting, the whole installation here.
Care for the style.
Metro, one of these missions, you may be the one in trouble.
Oh, a prehistory named Nietzsche once said,
for man to be the equal of God, he has to live dangerously.
It's true for us androids as well.
Surely, perhaps I'll write a book on the subject.
You're going to end up as a human being yet, Metro.
Now I expect to see them on our tail.
Oh, it'll be some time before they're operational again.
Try the radio, Metro.
It has to work now, and it's absolutely essential to notify Omega.
We might yet need their help.
When I think of it, a giant base run entirely by humanoids.
What are they doing there?
Whose orders are they following?
Who's behind it?
Worried, Matron?
I think I ought to tell you something.
I tested the walls.
They're made of a metal that is super hard, literally jam-packed with remarkable tools
and equipment, and there is a very powerful motor.
More powerful than any of those of the largest spaceships.
All that in a base with no clear mission.
We don't know the whole story.
How soon are we operational?
Very soon, Admiral. In a few hours. The damage was extensive.
At all costs, they must not escape. They know too much.
Too many errors in programming were allowed.
Colonel, we will hold you personally responsible.
Yes, sir. Response, logical.
Petro, look. Jupiter.
My Jupiter. Largest planet in the solar system. 1,300 times the size of Earth.
I guess they're not coming after us. We're rid of them.
Faster.
Only as far as Uranus. We're too slow.
Moving at cruising speed right now, Piero.
Ought to put us into hyperspeed to go where, and we wouldn't detect anything on the way.
Black's a little patience, old man, okay?
Yes, you're right. Sorry, I got a little carried away.
Rupiter, it's amazing it sends out such strong radio signals of its own, it drowns out all the others.
In fact, nothing can be detected near it.
Europa, the icy one.
And that one over there is Eo.
Eo, the volcanic.
You see that dark spot?
Several Earths could fit inside it.
You realize, Metro?
Where are the other satellites? They're 14 in all, if I am not mistaken.
Do you know their names?
Oh, what a silly question. Let's see, Ganymede, Callisto, the largest, and Amaltha, and let's see, the others are, um, let's see...
Metro, I really got you this time. In fact, the others don't have names. They're referred to by numbers.
Tell me, Metro, how did you manage to get control of our guard?
Right, back there, simple. I checked the walls, and when the guard came along, I created a sort of, um, a sort of interference.
I realized I could fuse all his circuits, so that's what I did.
Then it was child's play to separate out the circuits we needed so he could operate.
And then I went on to repair and reprogram these, and I must admit I'm not too displeased with the result.
Oh, you're really extraordinary, Metro.
A ship. It's enormous.
Metro fighter craft.
We have to make it to the asteroid belt. It's our only chance.
Evasive action.
There's danger.
The mission just reminded me. Remember Jurgle?
I wonder if that wasn't the risk that went...
...of dust compared to Ceres with a diameter of 1,000 kilometers, or even Pallas.
And you can count 13 or more of 300 kilometers diameter and 45,000.
Stop it, please, Metro. This really isn't the moment.
All right. Trying to help. I'm going to bore you.
Metro, look!
Another six. They know that we're here hiding, and they're out to get us.
Only the asteroids prevent them from finding us, but they won't give up.
We know of their existence, and whatever their intentions, they can't let us go.
Okay, Metro, get ready to go into hyperspace.
Into hyperspace in an asteroid belt, as they would say, conclusion illogical.
I know it sounds crazy, but to stay here is certain death.
But we don't even have a protection screen on this mini monstrosity.
Maybe, but that's not how I see it.
They won't follow us.
They'd consider it illogical.
We're going to try it, even if our chances are only 100 to 1.
Because staying here, we've no chance at all.
To your seat.
We're going into hyperspace.
At least put on your space suit.
You never know.
It might give you some protection.
Thank you, Metro.
That was nice of you.
Speed mode!
Sighted wreck of their ship.
No sign of life.
No other ships in sight.
No, Admiral. Sky is perfectly clear.
Very well. Return to base.
Try to radio our position.
Can't get into contact with Omega.
I'm not surprising with all the radiation the planet's sending out.
Well, I've had it. I can't stay awake. I think I'll sleep.
You're here. I'm so glad.
Quickly, waiting for you to guide you.
Okay, Psyche, here I come.
Motor's maximum velocity. Slow down now.
Here, Kim. I'm here.
You're where?
It's wonderful.
Yeah, how are we gonna get down to them?
We can land on that large rock.
Seems flat?
There shouldn't be a problem.
Have you been hurt?
I don't know, Pyrrho.
I guess I'm in shock.
All I know is I hurt all over.
Let's go.
All right, Om, you take it easy, okay?
Dear poor Metro.
What can we do?
I'll come back and get him.
I'm going back for Metro.
Life to him.
Very Psyche.
Maestro will fix him good as new.
I promise you he'll be going with us on lots of missions in the future.
You'll see.
It's your thoughtful wonders of Lucy.
Come take your place.
We're leaving soon.